fixing and sundry hi um okay so I'm
actually going to talk about paper it is
the intersection of the two programs
that are running right now the Institute
one is is the pseudonymous program and
the other is machine learning prog
program so so this is about this new
line of research with so a lot of work
in the past you're also new two year and
a half on on space bounded learning what
happens to learning to just normally
park learning where when you restrict
the space at the algorithm can use and
we give general result the give roll
down whenever the hypothesis class is
pseudo random you know in a natural way
so so this is what is talking about this
is jon worth with my my sister michelle
who's a who's a graduate student at the
Hebrew University she's out of the
neuroscience program there she does
machine learning but really she's
actually a see what computer scientist
and and this whole project started
because she heard about this kind of
machine learning machine machine
learning problem that had this fun
flavor furyk flavor and she thought that
this is a puzzle if you could solve ok
so I'm going to give kind of a we'll
talk in the sense that i'm going to talk
about about confusion about lower bounds
it's about how you know if you can't
remember everything you're a learner and
it can't remember everything and you
don't have em this time then you're
basically school is very easy to confuse
you i try to be the non confusing talk
about confusion ok
um okay so let's let's talk about
learning so so here is the basic fact
suppose that I have some hypothesis
class so i have x is a set of examples
and i have hypothesis each apophysis is
a function that gives for every element
in x either the old one labels it you
know with zero with one and what happens
is that someone picks some hypotheses
and now we keep seeing examples that are
consistent with that positives okay so
we see various exes don't form some
distribution and we see them labeled
with the evaluation of the apophysis on
them and kind of standard definition of
park learning says you know you want for
every a process this no matter what's
the underlying hypothesis no matter what
the distribution you get over examples
with high probability the learner will
come up with some approximation to the
to the underlying hypothesis that is
very good with respectable distribution
and and the fact is it's always possible
to learn after seeing all your
logarithmic number of hypotheses for
many classes you can actually do much
better but this is always true and
lovely it's because if you see random
examples they roughly cutting mostly cut
in half the space of possible hypotheses
so after long age examples nope yep s
prime is not equal to H
it stands go on what okay that's not the
ability of H prime not equal to H yes
yes not nothing thank you yeah when you
say one can learn you mean that there is
actually in a fish and algorithm to do
so or just an algorithm that would work
that's not necessarily there's an
efficient algorithm just get those
examples and just see what consistent
with that okay but but here is here is
the 11 point if we care about memory
implementing this algorithm actually
requires remembering all those log age
examples that you bought okay so so the
number of memory states you need is X to
the order log H which which is kind of a
little bit also H low bags also to to
the luggage log X and it could be a lot
look now the question is can we can we
also learn with with fuel memory state
and and we can buy both false learner so
so here is so the first observation is
that if we want to uniquely identify the
ipod's east at the end we need to have
aged memory states now Park learning
doesn't say that you have to identify in
the end maybe you do if if all the
processes are kind of far from each
other so an approximation basically
means that you also figure out what's I
policies maybe you can save a little but
but age is kind of the ballpark for the
new number of memory States you would
need and it turns out that you can
actually learn with this memo number of
men way states and what here's a hill
the algorithm I'm going to enumerate
each and every I prophecies I have let's
start with the first and i'll say okay i
think it's at first let's start seeing
examples I until I see something that is
inconsistent with that ok and then okay
no I saw something inconsistent so let
me move on to the second hypothesis let
me wait until I see something
inconsistent with that and so on so on
and in the end I will find out the right
both of this so I only need to remember
what's my current conjecture so that's
age memory state and an after age your
gauge examples I should I should know
what's going on what kind of x is for
the examples to assume like and simple
at any point in time we'll get the fresh
Rendon i get i get random examples i get
examples labeled with what's a 2d oh no
so let's plot what with what we know we
have those two x's how many memories
states we we have and how many examples
we have and we saw two algorithms the
first is this no the first one of them
was a brute force algorithm so it has
very few memories they just age which is
great but a huge huge number of examples
and we saw another algorithm which is
just a standard pet learner that uses
many memories states much much more than
H and but has this great memory usage
and and kind of the question is okay can
we get something in the middle meet in
the middle maybe can we improve things
so we use maybe a bit more than a
generally states with more than log H
examples but but get a good algorithm
and and this would be great okay so this
is the question victoria leigh the
question was raised actually as far as
we know by two independent groups one is
was a hot meal from the white one
institute and the other is a cool phone
from stanford like valiant and
Steinhauer and waiter and and they are
suppose that you want to learn with less
than what the puck learning needs
substantially less what can you do how
many examples do you need specifically
you have a question
specifically the second work actually
suggested the special case of parities
you get like something like X 1 so X 2
so X league so X 4 so on so on but you
don't know what what are the variables
involved in X or now learn just from
seeing examples and indeed some sometime
after this paper appeared unless found a
way to prove a long low bounds for
learning parities with with M variables
but it is with that variable so you have
the number two examples is two to the
end we don't want to the end and the
normal hypothesis right is any choice of
one of the subset of the of the
impossible variables to put in the
parity so a jeanette's are both 2 to the
N and he indeed show that you need
either something like edgy log X 0 H to
the Omega 1 in order to learn to learn
paratus okay so you just cannot improve
over those two basic algorithms sorry
I'm just so abscess is the examples ages
I offices so any so in this case H is
like possible paratus and exes would
access like the 01 to the end because
you get various exes and you get oasis
um okay and so his work was really
tailored to penalties it really really
used the fact that we're talking about
parities it asked okay so so if you
learn parities it makes sense to look at
a fine learners learners that only do
linear stuff and then full these sort of
learners he was able to prove a very
strong lower bound goodbye what kinds of
linear algebra and things like that and
then he showed that basically any
learner might as well be be linear okay
so he really settled this problem for
parities
many other in another work with with
Gareth colon Abhishek tile and they
consider it also smaller parities okay
so for example the main makes main case
that they they were interested in is
penalties will you only choose login out
of the end variables in for your parity
now why why did they care about this
this case because you know general
parities is very special class of
hypothesis parity is on on very few
variables actually it's like such a
small and like innocent class they just
actually contained in other classes that
people care about at B&N so coccyx like
this it does on local rhythmic number of
variables song so so this allow them to
get some results for some classes I
processes classes other than just you
know for parity and they show that you
need it'll super linear space or support
put normally many examples in n but it
still doesn't resolve kind of the big
question which is what about general
hypothesis class can improve lower
bounds when learnability with with
bounded space and in fact this was kind
of this was the question that Colin in
mind when when she first heard this
problem from for mohan and what i want
to tell you is it's about kind of our
solution to this question okay so i told
you that it's going to be a connection
between to the randomness and and
learning so let me introduce the the one
definition from super animus it will be
necessary here i want to consider a a a
bipartite graph that corresponds to my
hypothesis class so i have all
hypotheses on one side and I have all
the labeled examples on the other side
they don't have to be the same the same
this big might be notice that i'm
talking about labeled example so exemple
feels here with either 0 1 that is it's
possible label for it and i connect one
hypothesis with one example one labeled
example if the process is consistent
with this labeled example so if i get
like x and b then if age of x equals B
then I'm going to connect H X so this is
for me the bipartite graph that
represents this hypothesis class and
then i can ask about it pseudo-random
properties just the usual ways i'm going
to define the copy that the mixing if
for every set of hypotheses every
startup labeled examples you know i have
at mixing the number of edges i expect
is is what it would be in a random graph
with the same density up to up to kind
of the standard error okay and then kind
of day gives you what what's the
multiplier of this like standard
deviation company ok so what I want to
do is consider hypothesis classes that
that are mixing for example random
hypothesis classes are going to be
mixing they don't are not captured by by
parity is even by small parities so most
classes I'll not captured by parities
but but would be captured by this by the
way this is what we know about parity is
R squared H mix
so may feel one says any apophysis class
that is mixing has it all bound if you
take the the space bound to be the
abundant number of memory states be
sufficient then then you video is you're
going to need many many examples so so
here is here is the feeling i'm at least
a kind of simplified we can get slightly
better [ __ ] victories so suppose that
that positive class is all their squad x
mixing we can actually so it includes
penalties we can actually go above
parities and then you can even go above
this score discotheques so now let's say
it otoscope x then you need it on some
number of memory states all age to the
to the Omega 1 examples in order to
learn and the thing to notice is that
this this bound that we have on the on
the memory on the number of memory
states rights of this writing 44 helices
is used to be HT to the rock log X H to
the log X is actually not true for such
general classes but but probably
something better than then 1.25 the the
issue with this 1.25 is this is super
linear in H ok so so it's a right so it
was a challenge to get a super linear
number of memory states we hope that
we'll be able to to improve this but but
we don't know yet what's your injection
how far can you prove it you're saying
log accident I don't want to commit to a
conjecture no but but in particular also
the small parities on this call has a
towel is also mixing and they actually
have an example where you can do
slightly slightly better than age log X
okay okay so from now on I'm going to
denote the number of memory States my
lower bound my my the ballet i have on
the memory sizes be and I'm not going to
mention again what this B is and but
right but the point is that the number
of examples we pull this is really the
right thing you really show that you
need essentially age examples just like
what what we had mobility is in order to
to learn anything well will when you
have this bound on the memory so
pathetic you Logan meet beats are the
mixing hey guys are not as mixing right
so your Tito know that the el L is
mixing or even though again needs a
square root of two to the area because
it said it's a subgraph right this is
the thing about mixing it's a valuable
bust definition then if you apply your
bound and the amount i'm just trying to
see what they how does it compare full
so there's something much better they
have superb constant here Oh super
constant but not realize but but not H
to the log X I to the local ethics is
not true
okay okay so this is this is the main
theorem this is the best so we're
talking about proving lower bounds for
random I posix cus so this is actually
an interesting point usually we'll use
for circuits that looking at random
functions it's very easy to find
Global's right because it's counting on
humans and isn't that for learning kanji
documents don't work dealing with random
classes is really hard it wasn't known
until until this work so the bomb you
get for rental is worse than the in what
sense I know but here we're trying to
capture everything right it also depends
on how mixing right y'all you're
considering and and what other parameter
is spicy depends on right so it's not
really fair comparison okay good let me
help you you know my favorite thing
about this work is it the framework is
the fact that we have this combinatorial
way to think about to prove flow bounds
for space bounded learning and introduce
concepts that I think are really
important for all this study so so to me
this is the main contribution of this
work we give this pseudo randomness
sufficient condition this connection
between pseudo randomness and unlearn
ability with with bounded space you know
it's also nice that we have this just a
computer tutorial sufficient condition
for when something is going to be hard
and so the applications as I said for
most classes for random classes we get
low downs and for classes that are all
working codes in the sense that every
type offices
disagree on many on many examples we
also these are mixing classes and we get
results for them so this is the fewer
and you know you get a little bouncy
like for any pairwise independent yeah
we can get yeah we know many things that
are mixing and for all of them we get it
open okay so so we've all this down and
then and then we put it on the ECCC and
we sent an email to the people who
walked on those things to tell them hey
we have this new general result and one
of them was none of us and and a few
days later he writes to us that he took
and can get such a such a result oh it
is a related result so this is so you
eventually finished writing his thing
and it's now also on the ACCC and this
is what he pulls he considers an
algebraic notion of of mixing considers
the largest singular I ghen value of
this matrix that is very similar to the
graph that we consider we has this this
condition about the single value and
then he gets very strong very strong
results it actually generalized his his
previous work on penny-tees the work so
completely different right we're all
about like let's understand the concept
and the framework and let's be our
community really nice and and this is
all like algebra so I think that is you
know what to gain from from both on both
works
what I think they should imply mixing
yes but but it's but the other way is
not so obvious right there committal
mixing is a sound conference there are
some but but they don't they're not so
smooth right it's a stronger thing in
general to have this combinatorial
mixing ya know and this is also about
grabs and you can probably also do them
but the converse the parameters are not
so good in this in this villa linear
yeah yeah one of my AG does give better
parameters kind of the hope is it you
know the way the way we look at it we
wanted kind of this framework to be
known and and the belief is that we
should be able to also get the right
quantitative pounds we just just more
subtle than this doesn't give the result
for sparse parity doesn't not played it
no it doesn't you can actually
substitute them need secretly log square
in love yeah it substantially weaker
than most part where it is yes but
fujino paradisus matches useful general
parities it matches yes it was possible
yeah um more questions yes long each or
log thanks
it's actually a little gauge yeah this
is why it's not so strong for we're at
patha this is for long x you get sparse
panties what if this edge no it's just
not true is it with log X okay okay uh
okay so i wanna i want to tell you about
a work and so it's a nice combinatorial
kind of framework for thinking about
about your bounds and the first thing I
need to do is kind of tomorrow what what
a learner is so let's do that so suppose
if we pick some photos is this is going
to be our underlying hypothesis H and
then we're going to have a bunch of
memory states up to be memory states and
we start with some arbitrary memory
state on the first layer and each time
we're going to give some we're going to
get some labeled example chosen at
random and we're going to switch to a
new memory state that corresponds to the
next time and in general we we have this
this transition graph that tells us for
everyone was safe for every example we
get well what's the new memory state and
the whole thing is that the number of my
status is bounded and and so on and so
on so we actually have all those many
layers and in the end every memory state
is associated with an hypothesis and I
patha this is what we output if we reach
this this memory state you know this is
all I think that h3 is the right is the
writer and what is this if I if I got
here okay and what's going to happen is
that we're going to have a path for
every sequence of random examples that
we get it induces a path in this graph
that eventually results in
with a memory state that says some
hypothesis so this is a learner degree
the degree oh yes yes so it's like a
deterministic we're so so it's a
deterministic learner because yeah the
example okay um yeah okay oh okay what
is the error so if you're showing it
cannot learn this kind of functions it's
a totally uncorrelated so let's see ok
so here is the first concept that we
want to introduce to study those lower
bounds and this is a concept of
certainty so what we're going to do
right it's a lower bound the learner is
supposed to walk for every I processes
we're going to pick right just like in
abrasive method we're going to pick the
hypothesis at random so later we'll see
that we're going to tweak with that and
not quite pick it at random but but kind
of disallow a few a few processes and so
on so on but initially it will you know
let us speak it's completely unit on it
random now for every member we stay that
every time T we can ask how certain this
memory state is in in the identity of
the underlying hypothesis so we consider
all possible hypotheses and for each one
we ask what the probability that the
right answer is is age conditioned on we
reached this this memory state and we
take squares which means so so it will
absolutely sure so that is not going to
be just one thing that is that is one
then the song is one if we're really not
sure before like I could be anything I
basically still have the uniform
distribution over H then I'm going to
have some
age of 1 over H squared okay so I'll
have one in 1 over H okay so this is the
definition of certainty and we also look
at the finish of average 70 over all
possible memory states certain time and
it is here's what we say initially we're
just going to pick the photos is
uniformly at random and the certainty is
going to be 1 over H you know we don't
know anything we don't learn anything
but then what can happen is it you know
we see examples and and we have dead we
get more and more information and and we
have date or knowledge and then maybe
the certainty goes up okay so this is
the hope for well my learning algorithm
that's it in the beginning you didn't
know anything in the end it snows so in
the end we want a certainty to be say at
least Omega 1 right if you want we have
constant error okay so somehow the
certainty had to go from almost nothing
to really large and the question is
whether it can actually do that so what
we're going to show is that any learner
that has this bound on the novel memory
states at any time T now we need to
tweak things a little but then the
certainty doesn't go up by match the
certainty is essentially what it had
before it was before time something that
is about one okay so so a priori I see
an example an example gives you one bit
of information because we're talking
about like zero one labeled examples so
supposedly maybe the certainty increased
by 2 x factor to each time we say no it
increases because of the of the bound on
the memory it only increases by about
one okay and you can see from here that
to get to all the one what we need to
learn for h to the Omega 1
steps so this is what we what we get
okay then of course you can you can
change that right if you want different
certainty then you get slightly
different things here what is be here as
long as the impedance whatever we define
before I told you beings like the number
of memory stage this is the width l we
put something specific ok so this is our
first contribution this this idea of
certainty and and and the fact that
certainty may not go up unless you see
aug huge number of examples this is kind
of the the proof outline but I want to
kind of go over like go will be deeper
and highlight all the important
components and the other concepts as we
introduced ok so the first the first
question you may have your minds what's
the sort of one on this connection why
mixing what's going on so so this is
what what I try to enter now and I'm
going to demonstrate in the case of in
like a very very special case that we
call heavy steps what's a heavy step
this is a situation well you start with
a memory at time T and there was a very
large set of labeled examples that all
led to the same memory state at time T
plus 1 now this is a situation that may
occur in algorithms in particular the
boat false learner has heavy steps
because you know what what a memory
state is like it's i conjectured the
hypothesis is something so every every
example that is consistent with the
hypothesis huge number of examples is
leading to the same MO would stay that
says it says yes we still think that
will consistent we
this something I and every other thing
leads to a memory state that says my my
conjecture is the next step offices so
heavy steps may be really useful right
so this is this example it may go to all
the examples consistent with sorry
focuses each okay now what I claim is it
for heavy steps it's very clear why
mixing is is helpful why mixing implies
lower bounds what the situation the
situation suppose that the certainty
here is high all right because all we
want to show is that the certainty
doesn't write it stays high all the time
sorry it's sorry yeah it's a slow sorry
so so what's high is the number of
possible hypotheses ok so a memory stay
has many many possible hypotheses that
that are consistent with us being there
and and now it gets one of many many
examples so we have a very large set of
hypothesis or maybe even generally
distribution on hypothesis and then we
know that we got one of like a very
large set of examples okay and mixing
exactly and shows us that that we didn't
pretty gained much information because
the number of edges in between is kind
of what the same no matter so no matter
what we just write this is mixing we
didn't get mine in for much information
if all we know that the example is one
of many of many possibilities okay okay
so this is this is the any any questions
okay so so this is the first case in
this case of like many possible
hypotheses many possible examples
because of the mixing the certainty
doesn't go up I'm a little confused so
is it in a deterministic how could you
have a large set of like old examples
are you talking about consecutive time
steps or yeah tangible Swan so don't you
request a sample well when you say you
get a sample this is up so I'm not
talking about the transition that's a
transition breath randomly generated
yeah Oh every time cept you get a random
sample yes and I'm talking here about
the transition graph not about what
happens in some execution okay okay okay
so this case is a music case but then of
course this worked nicely only when
there were many possible examples we
didn't know which which example led let
us to hear and and the issue is that
maybe transitions such as there is maybe
only one example that leads here in
particular if we what we do is we save
the current example that we got in
memory it means that we go to this new
memory it is completely completely tells
us what this this example was right so
so this is this situation and the
question is what do we do in this
situation because here mixing doesn't
help us and this is the this is the hard
part but here is his idea the memo is
bounded right so what we haven't used
the fact that the memo is founded if the
memo is bounded you start with like be
memory states you ending be memory state
but every every
vertex every member i stayed at like x
possible things we may see so on average
we expect each time t plus one memory to
see something like X possible examples
okay so it's not right in this other is
and it keeps remembering all the
examples it sees it keeps kind of
expanding funding over and over and and
write a little collisions but if we have
bounded space we know that there must be
collisions okay so this is how we use
memory that the bounded memory and and
here's here's the idea well you know
this the fact that we got this this
labeled example here it may give us one
bit of information but you know what but
we do not show from which memory we got
and this is what's supposed to confuse
the algorithm this is kind of the
intuition accept it as is this is false
because what can happen suppose that you
know you may have many many possible
memories or leading to hear but for each
of them that the set of possible
hypotheses that makes sense is the same
okay so this is the situation that is
equivalent basically to I have you know
one memory with some subset of possible
hypotheses and now i get another bit of
information so so obviously my certainty
went went up
so the idea is we need something more
than that what we need to say is that if
I have many many possible memory state
and I look at what are the possible
hypotheses that I'm consistent with them
I get things all over the place I can
get the same set and this brings us to
maybe the second big concept here which
is the concept of offer of a knowledge
graph and in k expansion k for knowledge
so what's a knowledge graph it is graph
that summarizes what we know are at
certain times time step like we may be
in each one of those memories those all
the time T memories and we may have each
one of those hypotheses and and we
connect and one and then we wait or die
potus's that could be good that are
consistent with with it okay like so so
every NGO corresponds to there is a way
this is the right I policies to get to
this memory state so this kind of
represents exactly what kind of all the
information we have about about i
prophesy that the memory states and how
they correspond to hypothesis is a
certain time okay and we're going to
define some notion of expansion 40 this
graph it's kind of usually when you talk
about expansion we talk about regular
graphs this graph is just you know
whatever comes from the algorithm so it
can be highly irregular so you need to
be very careful about your yo pseudo
randomness definitions but we do that
and then we want to say k expansion
would be that like sufficiently large
sets or distributions with enough
entropy here correspond to many possible
like basically the uniform distribution
the uniform distribution of hypothesis
okay and if this is the case what we can
say we have like a large subset of
memories there are many right well
basically uniform over the vet offices
and and and and here we only get one bit
of information on something uniform of
the Lord we don't have much information
here okay okay
any questions about this out of
now the main thing is that we need to
show that k expansion is preserved the
expansion exists in the beginning and it
continues to exist at every time step
because it really need it at every time
step and and this is this is what we do
and the interesting thing is that we
need a scientist below in order to to
get K expansion so we have this this
argument that says well if you have low
certainty and would k expansion then you
will continue to have low certainty but
also you have a good k expansion and low
certainty you'll continue to have
expansion in this way we can you know
continue throughout all the many
iterations okay and so this is roughly
luckily they are human for y YK
expansion is preserved we start right so
suppose this is this is my new knowledge
graph between time T plus 1 memories and
die patha this and time T plus 1
memories came from time T memories we
are out transition brats and what we
want to show is that if we start with
the distribution with enough enough
entropy here then we end up being nearly
uniform here and and here's what what we
do we say well if we have memories of
high probability of sufficiently high
probability here they must have become
for memories with sufficient high
probability here and also the examples
leading here had had to have sufficient
high especially high quality okay so
what we're going to do is to focus only
on memories here that have low certainty
we assume that there is no certainty
over also so there should be many such
many such memories each of them has many
possible hypotheses now we'll doing this
transition we know that there is a good
probability to reach the green set and
and so because of mixing we know that we
don't get a lot of information from this
transition from this example and we can
say we don't get too much information
from here because we knew that we had k
expansion before okay so so basically
this is this is the argument clothes dog
many details and and the whole thing is
is quite intricate okay okay so this is
what I wanted to say about the proof let
me talk a bit about about open programs
so one thing that we we show this mixing
is the sufficient condition for lunner
ability and and one question is whether
it's also essentially necessary right we
have very strong lower bounds very
strong lower bounds for mixing classes
those low bones based on blow bounds
only hold when when the classes are
mixing maybe maybe not and then in
general what we would like to have is a
full theory of vulnerability with
bounded space what we would want to have
this for every interesting hypothesis
class say okay the trade-off between
time and memory is this this is the
diagram that it gives it so so we made a
lot of strides for towards tories by
considering all kinds of special classes
yeah but what we still don't cover
everything wait okay ne ne yeah plenty
of questions
so what are the new oh sorry what is the
new what does some new I mean not that I
mean gonna give some specific new
examples where you get I mean where yo
conditions and random random classes no
one knew how to say anything about my
new classes before whenever classes
would not contain parity is no reason
for them to contain priorities what
about like so one thing what's wrong
rather like causes work is this
applications to buy the storage one this
applications to cryptography asperities
actually good because they keep official
encryption scheme and we felt like s in
this sense any other animal DNA and
modernizer learning but anything else
that might delete the like a new
candidate encryption schemes against the
space bounded out or so on so which
which I Papa this class would you like
to see I don't know what I guess what
there is no special computer it this
thank you this is your okay yeah so for
AC 0 we don't have the right we know
that we don't have the right
quantitative results and and this could
be a way to get the right quantitative
results problem we of course need to
improve our quantities for this to
display your condition of middle school
maybe say what does satisfy roses yeah
DNFs already did they satisfy this
understand like the roles of
distribution I should think of this
result is like bringing any distribution
it's true our distribution by
distribution level for learning with the
random examples so right the limos job
is is to to deal with every distribution
so it's enough that we show some
distribution okay but we actually we
actually considered very concrete
distributions which are essentially be
uniform about or hypotheses we later
modified slowed somewhat like as time
progresses we may throw out hypothesis
if we don't like but we don't fall out
too much crap I was mixing any put one
that wasn't put them together no butBut
right the the question should not be
understood in literally it should be
understood thing can you extract from
every from every ipod for this class
that has the strong bound can you
extract something that is mixing
get me actually prove something went to
the randomest like an they asked like if
you can if you seek using this number of
examples not only you cannot learn but
in third you know the answer that some
such a pseudo-random like when lips an
application basically this is what
follows from am i what we what we do
thank you basically basically say you
don't see enough examples and you have
this bound on the memory then you
basically don't know more validation
don't you get something like 1 over H uh
yeah which is really good if you write
if you have h for privacy they said like
you know for parity sample just says
that if you don't see enough example the
cipher exciting maybe we should take
another question yeah I'd be happy to
enough to think about specific
application okay pull the single again
[Applause]